the world met fictional cia super agent
mitch wrap back in 1999
in a series of novels by the late author
that would be vince flynn
now the character's coming to the big
screen the movie american assassin
is based on the new york times
bestselling book of the very same name
actress dylan o'brien
american assassin all right and taylor
kitsch he is too starring the action
thriller
o'brien is rap a cia black ops recruit
he's on a mission to stop a mysterious
operative played by kitsch
from starting
where is he i know
you're talking
where is he you outside
oh the movie's distributed by cbs films
which is a division of cbs corporation
dylan o'brien
and taylor kitsch join us at the table
we welcome you thanks for stopping guys
in the control room i said
what do you want us to say about the
movie and they both said just say how
wonderful and good we are
but you're both playing you know sort of
badass killers both of you
on opposite sides dylan for you and
taylor for you this meant what for you
what were you trying to play what were
you trying to i think i think what
what's
so different from other films as well
like this is is a big difference from
friday night lights just a tiny bit yeah
tiny bit even though he is from texas
i know he is but um is how personal that
circle
or that triangle is with uh keaton's
character as well of just my character
coming through that program 10 years
earlier
and having the same motive of going
through that making a difference in
serving this country
to being jaded through the trauma like
mitch rapp went through as well and how
each character deals with
that trauma so differently well cause
you start out dylan very motivated yeah
there's a reason why you got involved in
this
yeah that was and uh it's my favorite
thing about the character i mean i
really am honored to play him
you know i mean i feel like there's so
much uh um
trauma there as taylor said and he kind
of represents uh
the path that mitch rap can go down you
know in a way
um i just always felt like it was really
emotional really authentic really
compelling and that it was
uh you know a really believable arc in a
way for a character and
yeah it was interesting too to see
michael keaton
yeah the scenes between michael keaton
and you
and all three of you he's in the movie
yeah yeah no
you i found out from you in a couple
scenes let me just say dylan has quite a
sense of humor because i was talking
about michael keaton he goes was he in
the movie what did he play
okay it's a very dry sense of humor yeah
yeah it was good it was a he's an
up-and-coming actor you know
come under our wing and she should have
happened yeah showed him the reps a
little bit yeah what did you learn from
him
uh nothing yeah actually became
way worse
yeah really no for me it was it was a
big reason to sign on i have one
like long scene with him that's a pretty
rare memorable scene and um you know
he's just a gamer still has great energy
as just improv yeah he really does and i
think
you just come really motivated that day
too you both are doing all of your own
stunts
as much as the studio allow us but there
are stuff
where it's like you know there's a lot
of stunt work this scene right here on
the on the speedboat
yeah for a very long period of time yeah
it's a big deal now the stunts i mean
tom cruise was hurt on the subtle latest
mission impossible there was a death
yeah on the scene of deadpool 2. so it's
been it's been a topic of discussion i
wonder when you guys are
thinking about and figuring out what
you're going to do how do you how do you
process that you have to go about it in
a meticulous way you know i think it's
it's just easy on set to
kind of get lost in that kind of world
of make-believe in a way and you have to
remember that things are still real
and you know you just gotta everyone has
to do their part everybody has to
you know vet everything when you're
trying to do something that is dangerous
and
forget uh not forget that you know it
can be dangerous and people can get hurt
i mean it's you know have you been hurt
have i been hurt yeah
uh yes i have yeah did you know that
information indeed
so you're prompting me
a pretty bad onset accident myself so
you know i've i've
i've seen how it can go wrong and um
yeah just going forward i just think
it's it still just can't be happening
anymore you know
and it's also very timely what's going
on all the uh
intrigue that's going on in this country
about how the government works i also
thought was interesting taylor
yeah i mean yeah no i thought you're
gonna have one
this it's not going anywhere this this
terrorism
and everything that's going on these
events and and
so i think that's really a big part of
this movie but
more importantly what we wanted to deal
with was just how to ground it
and not over dramatize it and understand
that this is way more personal to begin
with between these three guys
and that was a huge part even talking
script and these guys their relationship
together a lack thereof as well
and vince lynn's widow came to the set
yeah lisa yeah she's great yeah she's
been really behind the movie and it's
really great because
it's just uh it's really heartwarming
thing you know i mean i think it's a
it's an honor for all of us to be able
to finally bring this to life and
um and i think it just warms her heart
and she's so supportive about it and
it comes in this great screen yeah i
smell a sequel based on how it ended
which i won't reveal i smell a sequel oh
we will see dylan o'brien and taylor
kitshby thank you
thank you american assassin opens in
theaters on september 15th